Uuuuuu faire
Ouais
[musique]
moi
Je suis venu ici Yamama 15 minutes
Si tu dis aller sur la lune, elle viendra de plus en plus
À cause de cela, maintenant Taiwan est devenu un corps.
Je te le donne, mais ma température corporelle fait partie de la Chine
Cette zone est la plus dangereuse si elle se transforme en
il n'y a pas
[musique]
Ouais
Impression générale de la digestion au large
je pensais que ce serait
Ogre eno
missile balistique
Démarrage ou sans type
600 seront étirés
au comité
opération
Je veux dire, ça a beaucoup baissé.
Mushu
pas
[musique]
Le mois sous étude et 3 épisodes-carry ou 1 type
question masculine
Au lieu de cette joie de corde, ne divisez pas l'île
Vie d'échecs de la force d'autodéfense
Watami fleurit et achète des balles
C'est exactement ce que je fais dans mon pays
N'est pas
[musique]